and action euphoria has got to be one of
the most visually stunning shows of the
last decade the lighting the camera
shots it's all just pure magic let's
take a look behind the sets at how they
made it all happen the energy is just
like really high and intense
number one this is a bit of a pun demi's
friend brynn jones helped with the set
design just in case you don't know who
that is she's the owner of arelda
vintage and she brought in a bunch of
clothes from her shop it was like my
dream closet the inspiration for the
store came from bryn pennypinching
throughout college and the store became
a reality when she'd landed a couple of
big modeling gigs and put the money
towards opening a brick and mortar shop
walking in and being able to try on all
those gowns was definitely a highlight
we kind of love the self-made story
about the business it seems to fit well
with our favorite euphoria characters
number two say cheese when it came to
shooting the new year's eve party they
wanted to approach the ominous tension
of the new year the wish or the hope
that that the new year is going to be
different they wanted to tell it with
snapshots like fleeting moments of
emotions to look like photos of someone
at a party so they turned off all the
lights and used a giant 20k spotlight
and just flashed it for a second number
three imagine having your own personal
carnival it would probably get boring
real quick you know having fun
no yeah
sam wanted a setting that was dreamy but
based in reality like the heightened
sense of reality that goes with being a
teenager the carnival became the perfect
location for that but definitely wasn't
the easiest to construct doing the
storyboarding was a huge challenge
because they were creating storyboards
for a carnival that didn't exist so
coordinating it was incredibly
complicated they built the carnival like
two days before we started shooting so
the team spent a lot of time there
trying to figure out the shots and
adjust the storyboards to the actual
location the carnival was set up in a
way that they could plan their 300-foot
track shots so you'd feel like you're
constantly looking through different
things and people to create that truly
clustered sense of a carnival and the
goal was to make it look like the whole
scene was done in one single shot but it
was actually done in about five pieces
it took six nights to film it and
zendaya found it so cold and dusty that
she needed an inhaler
number four don't actually let the
actors behind the wheel please yo what's
good start the car and be ready
sure thing
there's an art to crafting compelling
car scenes for tv like creating fun rigs
to mimic street lamps and lights
fastening super expensive equipment to
the front of real vehicles or instead
maybe laying 600 feet of track along the
main road you've got to shut down for a
day and tick off the locals not to
mention spending a bunch of time
planning the shots ahead of time oh or
maybe just going all the way and having
the vehicle be piloted by somebody else
entirely number five the most important
factors in euphoria
zendaya admits there was a ton of
pressure to have season 2 live up to the
hype of season 1. despite how popular
the look of season 1 was sam levinson
wanted to create something that had the
heart and soul of euphoria but looked
different and felt different he said if
season 1 felt like a party at two am
season two should feel like five am way
past the point in which everyone should
have gone home while season one felt
very present season two feels more like
the memory of high school last season
was blues and purples and season two is
all black and gold the crew reached out
to kodak to remake ektachrome for 35
millimeter camera and kodak actually
converted their factory in order to do
it the ectochromes intended to give
bright whites moderately enhanced colors
with a neutral balance low contrast tone
scales and extremely fine grain and we
treated them only as spirit pieces
number six they're like giant mazes
i'm going to take you into stage 14 and
show you where we film euphoria while
the cast is recording in another sound
stage the crew is hard at work building
the facades for the next round of shoots
and these sound stages are absolutely
huge so huge in fact that they need maps
to get around but we also got a little
peek at what we think is a shot from
season 2 of filming recognize these
places we never realized it before but
sound stages look like super dangerous
places when you've got giant lighting
rigs just chilling on the floor better
watch where you step
number 7. do you get motion sick too
because we sure felt a lot like rue just
from watching imagine responding to that
casting call where you need to be glued
to a roof ok they weren't glued in they
had to be strapped in while the room was
spinning and drew was wall crawling it's
really disorienting i think being in
there the crew built a gigantic room
that rotated around in a circle it was
built on a gimbal when roo walks out of
the bathroom that was built in a way
that it could break away so that their
camera could follow her in because of
course it couldn't be strapped to the
floor what was really cool is shooting
the rotating room number eight it's
obviously los angeles but nobody will
say it out loud the filming locations
give it away real quick fesco and
ashtray's business was shot in ultadina
dairy store located in temple city we've
found tons of photos from the euphoria
gang's time at the store it's kind of
weird how the masks really put a time
stamp on filming huh they also rented
out a bowling alley for a few days
bolium lanes the travel inn in north
hills got used once again in season 2.
other filming spots were favorite liquor
in burbank oddball cabaret in north
hills and frank's coffee shop in burbank
as well which is where roo met with her
sponsor ali in the between seasons
euphoria special you know what though we
would pick a soundstage over a real
location any day there's no battling
with the elements and all of the
lighting is done in studio meaning you
don't have to do the night shift we
think
number nine that feel when you control
the weather did you ever wonder how they
make it rain in hollywood and we're not
talking money it would be a little goofy
to wait for the appropriate weather so
instead they have this fun gadget and
they have to hose down all of the
streets it seems so simple but it's
definitely more complicated than a
garden hose which by the way are more
complicated than you think number 10.
euphoria just wouldn't be euphoria
without its lights
it's probably one of the strongest
storytelling elements the team has at
their disposal did you know that
lighting balloons are a thing yeah
they're just giant balloons with lights
inside which actually sounds so much
more convenient than needing all the
other giant contraptions it can take to
hang a light in a space there's no harsh
edges to these lights either and
euphoria gets good use out of them
material was like coming in and we look
at it just like going like wow this shot
is phenomenal we wonder how well they
work on a windy day though and how long
they take to deflate and that isn't even
close to the only cool lighting euphoria
makes use of there's also a couple of
cool rainbow ones and these big ol red
ones or this one can you attach them to
the scenes they're used in
number 11. are there schools out there
that actually have budgets big enough to
sustain big dances like this ulysses s
grant high school stood in for the
exterior shots of east highland high
school which is also the school where
saved by the bell was filmed but most of
the interior shots were actually done on
a sound stage welcome to our school
dance and the school dances were
mind-blowingly complicated did you see
all of the colorful lights in the
hallway before we even got to the dance
part and there were three thousand stars
strung up above the dance floor not to
mention an entire balloon hall we wonder
whose job it was to blow all those
balloons up number 12 we're just gonna
take a quick peek we also get this
awesome behind the scenes shot of the
strip club when it's still being built
and all we can say is tripping hazards
tripping hazards everywhere
number 13 these need to make a proper
comeback this was an intense moment
wasn't it to say somebody's sobriety
relies on you is one heavy burden it
seems really good it's called the view
you know
euphoria isn't the only show to use this
roller way glee famously used the same
space in one of their april roads
episodes
number 14. how do you top a carnival
marching bands apparently i want to do a
musical number and it'll be beautiful
and it'll be heartbreaking 200 people
were playing instruments and dancing and
singing in the streets of an average
suburb on the outskirts of la which
really created an interesting dichotomy
for rue's experience the track that they
played labyrinth was really the anthem
sam had playing in his head from the
beginning zendaya was thrilled by the
prospect of singing the song however she
wanted to do it her own way she was like
i'm not gonna do that but i'm gonna do
my version euphoria is definitely a go
big or go home kind of show
number 15. it's more complicated than
you'd think we don't always think about
how shots like these are handled do we
those over the headshots obviously take
more work than somebody with a camera in
their hands and we never think twice
about it it's a whole thing to attach it
to a gurney and then balance it back out
number 16
euphoria spares no expenses when it
comes to the coolest shots and tv
getting dressed i want to go swimming
and here they go with the underwater
cameras
some shows you watch to be entertained
others you watch because they're a work
of art euphoria is both of course more
than the sets it is truly the lighting
that gives euphoria that
euphoric feel and the camera that puts
us in that nostalgic mood what do you
think was the most visually stunning
scene in euphoria let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you